welcome to the annual in two part
lecture this election doubt by the part
and before introduce nachiket part I
want to tell you a little bit about the
role that the family is played in
establishing South Asian Studies at Yale
dr. Provine part and in Dubin came to
Yale in the nineteen late 1960s they
were from Gujarat and were closely
associated with the Gandhian movement
McGann himself congratulated ravine pine
indo indo ban on their wedding
dr. Park first came to the u.s. to
pursue postgraduate studies at Tulane
and returned to Yale in the department
of comparative medicine in 1968 after
his retirement he turned his attention
to promoting the study of India and
South Asia at Yale he himself was one of
our first Hindi language instructors and
he served the secretary to the South
Asian Studies committee which was its
earliest form of the council and I was
advocate in a supporter for the South
Asian Studies Council through the 1990s
and the family supports two annual
lectures which has brought in people
from South Asia to address both
questions of research and of
contemporary importance as well as
supporting a range of travel fellowships
for students to go to South Asia and
work we feel dr. Patz absence very
keenly this year this is the first year
he passed away last year and is the
first year he's not with us for the
lecture but we're very grateful to have
nachiket here to sort of address few
words
welcome everybody it's so nice to see
everyone here it's just a little bit odd
because usually it's my dad so I just
want to say a couple things this is
something that was a labor of love so
when we saw talk about what is being a
Gandhi and my parents grew up in the
free India movement my dad was born in
23 my mom in 27 they married in 46 they
married they were engaged in a prison
because my grandfather on my father's
side was a writer as well as an
educationist
and he started agrarian schools in in
Gujarat to look at a number of different
ways of raising the educational
attainment of rural villagers so with
that being a writer and writing against
occupation he was jailed a few times and
my maternal grandmother my maternal
grandfather was dying they were
betrothed to be married and yet both
grandfathers wanted my mother to finish
her studies she was getting a degree in
economics and she did well she completed
that before she was moving in and the
idea was was that for them that they
were part of this movement and then he
espoused it in their lives they lived
here in the States in a very simple
austere way yet they put forth things
that mattered to them after medicine my
dad retired he was retired didn't need
to do anything further but he felt a
need for South Asia and so did my mom
they both enjoyed students regularly at
their home my mom shared so many things
about that and for her women's rights
children rights were that important and
so today's more than fitting to honor
them and to be here to listen to dr.
Banerjee talk about some most important
work so thank you thank you
[Applause]
it's also my privilege to introduce our
speaker for today dr. Luke Winnie
Banerjee Robin if I could invite you to
come to the front so dr. Banerjee is
currently the CEO of platinum which is
one of is India's largest nonprofit
research group doing both research and
advocacy in the field of education dr.
Banerjee trail is an economist was
educated at st. Stephen's College Delhi
School of Economics was a road Scholar
to Oxford and finished a PhD at the
University of Chicago she began a career
as a program officer in the Spencer
foundation set up by Lara Spencer which
sort of seeks to do public policy work
in the field of Education and moved to
India 1996 to work with pretermit of the
leadership team Pratham was set up as an
NGO initially to provide education to
children in the slums in Bombay but it
grew collaborating with governments
communities and importantly parents and
teachers to make interventions to
address gaps in the education system and
to think of how public education has
changed in India the focus in the late
90s early 2000 was really on enrollment
in schools but despite enrollment
figures going up quite dramatically in
the early 2000s one of the things that
platform and the us a report that
Rukmini was instrumental in in doing was
to show that increase in enrollment
didn't necessarily lead to increase in
learning outcomes and the sort of key
intervention the pithre made was really
to focus on both measuring and improving
learning outcomes in schools prior to
becoming the CEO Raquin he led a sort of
Lisa thumbs research division and was
instrumental in creating the annual
status of Education reports which are
dedicated sub-continental assessment of
learning sort of reviewing over 600,000
children each year through its scale
annual persistence and sort of bottom-up
approach sort of changed the fundamental
debate over questions of learning in
India today Pratham has operations in 21
of India's 29 States reaches millions of
children and young people from Kashmiri
dominar and the methods of assessing our
learning outcomes have been
you know exported across India's borders
and has inspired parallel citizen-led
initiatives to focus on learning
outcomes in schools one of the most
delightful things of sort of writing
this I wish to discover Rukmini has
another career as a writer of children's
books in in Hindi and English which are
a part of breadth of pedagogical so
welcome to you and I I'm used to
speaking to school children so I have to
stand up I hope that's okay it's a real
pleasure to be here what
Rohith didn't say is that I have
connections to several of his family
members which I only discovered after he
wrote to me to come here he is one of
the first studies that I did in my in
the first year I did alone and the
second year I had some people and one of
the key people was his mom when we
started the asar effort in 2005 in the
first year his brother was a key part of
it and so these are these are just
stories I've put together once he wrote
to me and I think you mentioned who you
were so then I could maybe make the
connections it's it's really an honor to
be here I think it's a really an honor
to be part of something that your family
has started mr. but I have a small
little story on the side that I thought
I should say so that I can connect to
the especially to your to your mom I'm
sure she would have known the
connections in 1917 I think Gandhiji
went to be hard and I'm from Bihar and
they went you know as part of the
Champaran movement and while what
Gandhiji did became you know made the
nation's history perhaps what Kasturba
did didn't reach quite the same level of
publicity but the ashram in which they
lived is in a place called pity her
which is in a very you know it's it's
even today it's about maybe 50
kilometers from the district
headquarters and another probably 50
kilometres you hit Nepal so it's really
in a very tucked away corner of Bihar
and for the centenary of the Champaran
movement you know a lot of different
things were done in Bihar and as is
traditional if you actually go to the
ashram and you talk to people there they
say people come twice a year once for
Gandhiji's birthday and one for his
death anniversary and the rest of the
time - um is you know left to its own
devices and I I have a we have a big
team in Bihar and they felt that they
need to do something to honor the you
know not so much what happened with the
indigo planters but because the whole
country will honor that but to do
something about the fact that Kasturba
lived in that ashram and tried to do a
lot in the local community for education
for health for sanitation and so on and
there's a big scheme in India now called
the Kasturba Gandhi Balika Vadhu le
which is a costumer Gandhi and Malika is
girls and with the LA schools which are
residential schools which have been set
up by the government in very backward
blocks to help girls who for one reason
or the other either have left school or
at risk of leaving school and there is
actually in that location a costumer
Balika Vadhu le and so two things
happened one was that some of my young
colleagues and Pratap felt that they had
to do something that you know that would
be the tradition of a true tradition of
Gandhi Gandhiji is used in many ways in
India today by many kinds of people and
I think he's truly a public good so
people should be free to use him but we
wanted to do something that was me I
perhaps true then then what is normally
done and so twelve of my colleagues
actually walked from partner to be tea
halwa which is a distance of I
to 300 kilometres perhaps and they took
about 18 days and they stopped every
night in a in a village and they carried
with themselves only like I think one
change of clothes and a mosquito net the
mosquito net was my idea because I think
oh I don't know how Gandhiji dealt with
mosquitoes but but I think you need to
sleep it over ski tonight and along the
way people took care of them and they
talked a lot and this was in the month
of April so you really had to leave very
early in the morning and so you spent
the rest of the day in the village and
they you know had many adventures and
learnt many things and you know we
decided after that that we need to do
not just a walk which you know of course
was a very important thing to do but we
are now working in meteor WA in the
Balika Vadhu le but also in about a
cluster of 20 schools around and that
has been quite an adventure and we hope
to be there for at least the next three
to five years
Gandhiji himself was there for about a
year and more but we think change takes
a long time so I'm sure your mother must
have known this story because when they
were there it seems that they could not
mobilize a lot of the local people to do
some of this work I mean there was a lot
of involvement in the you know the work
that was happening with the indigo
planters but on the basic education and
basic health not very many people joined
them and they sent out a message to
their friends and many of their friends
came from Gujarat and elsewhere to live
with him there and they lived in the
ashram so perhaps I will keep you
informed of what happens very well yeah
this was an aside it's a it's a it's
it's really a pleasure to be here I
think my is a clicker
[Music]
I'm mindful of the instructions I've
been given by the gentleman at the back
so I'm not moving too much yeah okay
what what I thought I would do today and
I know we want to leave enough time for
actually a conversation last night I
went out for dinner with let's see some
of the people I went out for dinner
perhaps in this room and they asked me
many questions and so I was thought that
would be a good idea too
I say I'll talk for a little bit but
then maybe open it up my story starts
let's see how did this work okay so my
story starts this is a school it's a
risk this is just an ordinary school in
Bihar I had a phone call some years ago
and the voice sounded young the person
introduced themselves as a district
magistrate of this district in Bihar
called Jahan Abad and for those of you
you know I'm sure everybody here knows
who our district magistrate is he's cut
off the head of the district
administration it's usually a post that
young bureaucrats get after a year or
two in service so they're still quite
quite young and he called me and he said
you know I have a problem and somebody
gave me your number and perhaps you can
help to advise me what is the problem he
said you know we are a small district
the district has about 800 schools or so
so it's a relatively small district for
India and he said that I have I've tried
everything
you know the attendance in my school is
quite low am i doing okay yes the
attendance in my school and my schools
is quite low it was a time at which you
know the Bihar government had done quite
a lot of work in you know bringing
children to school and they were
beginning to monitor how schools are
functioning and he said that you know
I've tried everything I know how to do
so I made sure that most teachers are in
school because that's a common complaint
that people have the teachers don't go
to school I have made sure that all our
textbooks are distributed in time
our scholarships and all the other
entitlements that the government has
they're all going I have a you know the
structure and the district is under the
district there are blocks which are
about 100 or 150 schools and there are
people at the block level and then there
is a cluster which is about 15 or 20
schools so there are officials at each
level and he said I've made sure that
they move around and having done all of
this which I feel is in my hands to do
as a bureaucrat I was hoping that the
you know attendance would go up but it's
still really at 70 percent and we seem
to be unable to make it go higher now
this was a time at which the Bihar
government was reviewing attendance in
districts quite regularly and Johanna
Banda was one of the highest attendance
districts and yet it was still at
whatever 60 70 percent so he said I
really don't know what else to do but
having you know of maybe 30 percent or
more of kids not in school on a regular
basis is not a good thing if we think
schooling is important and you know I
was very impressed by the way he stated
the problem because he had sort of
worked his way through what he could do
and at the point that he was he was sort
of saying that now I don't know what
else to do if I just stop there and take
a step backwards and you know I'm sure
some of you are historians here and I
have some historians who are my close
friends who always say you can't talk
about the present without you know going
back I thought that was what older
people did but back gaurantee that's a
historical principle so you know and the
same friend said to be that it all
starts with the fact that Nehru made a
big mistake
and narrows biggest mistake is that he
didn't give enough importance to primary
education so I leave this as a question
to the historians and others in this
crowd about what Niro did right or wrong
but I would say that over the last
thirty years or more perhaps whatever we
didn't do straight after independence
has been done and
you know we are not that different from
many other countries who believe that
you know every child should be in school
and therefore may have made you know the
government parents everybody I think
there's consensus which has only grown
in the last at least 25 years that every
child should be in school and today in
India we are at a condition where I mean
not today I think this has been the case
for almost 10 or more years that more
than 95% children are actually enrolled
in school there is still as we were
talking earlier last 5% which may be
difficult and may have issues but by and
large we have schools everywhere we have
schools within one kilometer of
children's homes in you know most places
and to give you an idea that it's not
just that we have high enrollment if you
go back and even 10 years ago and look
at how many children were reaching
eighth grade if you look at the census
the last census in India almost every
age group so how many how many
six-year-olds seven year olds ten year
olds are there in India a rough number
is about 25 million in each age group
and so if you look at eighth grade
enrolment in two thousand seven or eight
the number was about twelve thirteen
million so off 25 million ten years ago
about half had reached eighth grade and
if you look at the numbers more recent
numbers maybe from two thousand
seventeen or eighteen that number is
close to 23 million so in this ten year
period not only have we ensured that
almost everybody is enrolled but I think
it's now the case that almost everybody
stays at least in the end of eight years
at the end of elementary schooling and
this is you know may you know many
people can claim credit for it many
policies can claim credit for it you
know we guarantee schooling in eighth
grade and I think we are we are almost
achieving it so from the point of view
of my district magistrate you know he
was also reiterating the fact that he
has high enrollment the problem is that
you know enrolment is high but
I remember asking a triac lass in in you
pee the world in Hindi for enrollment is
a big word it's called naman Khan and so
I asked the children because on the
blackboard in many classrooms they say
'no Monken and then they say opacity
which is attendance so I said what is
the Monken and the kids gave a very good
explanation one of the kids got up and
said naman can come with lab hacky-sack
UNAM school ah yeah everybody's name has
come to school and therefore this gap
between everybody's name coming to
school and everybody coming to school
you know varies in the country varies
day by day where is on the seasons and
my DM of Johanna Barr was worried about
the fact that there was you know this
gap if I look back even at our own
history in proton you know we came
across this problem some years ago our
tag line or I think it's called mission
statement is every child in school and
learning well and we think that every
child in school and learning well is
important but even in our first some
years we worked a lot on the every child
in school because it even in bombed we
started a long way even in Bombay they
were in say nineteen ninety six or seven
they were still some sections of
children who were out of school but as
we work there
you know we too began to feel this you
know the visibility of the children out
of school is obvious you know you can
see kids who are out of school you still
see some kids that traffic lights or you
know playing in the you know fields in
the village and so on but the feeling
that we had was that the visible problem
is there and people are tackling it but
there are some problems you're not as
visible and the invisible problem was of
the kind that you are in school but
you're not really as parents would say
that you know they're not learning as
much as we mean that things are not
happening as much as we thought teachers
feel that you know I'm working hard but
somehow it's not going as far as we want
and if you look at kids behavior I
always thinking think that watching kids
is actually the best way to understand
what's going on
you see a lot of children in India
especially in government schools after
lunch who are outside you know it's not
like they are working but they are doing
a lot of other things which are perhaps
more fun so in a funny way you feel this
problem which is the real problem that I
see is that teachers are getting
discouraged because somehow things are
not happening parents are getting
disappointed because a lot of parents
whose children are in school today
haven't had much schooling themselves
and so there are very high aspirations
from education and the kids are just
disinterested because whatever is
happening outside seems to be a little
bit more fun and this perhaps is the
problem that both the district
magistrate of Jehan Abad felt more
recently and we felt earlier so how do
you get to the you know what is the
problem clearly one issue that we felt
was that you know it's difficult for the
teachers and the children to cope with
what ought to happen in the classroom
and the parents can't cope with it
because often there they don't know
quite what to do and so you know if we
think that the real problem now is
children are in school but they're not
getting what they ought to be getting or
the value added then you need to
concretize that a little bit and even
for us working in program how to make
this more concrete how to make it more
visible was important because otherwise
you can't tackle a problem unless you
really understand it you know how do you
understand the problem different people
have different ways of getting at it and
we felt the best way for us to
understand the problem was to spend more
time with the children and really get at
what is why is this core interaction
that education is about which is the
thing that happens between teaching and
learning one is the problem right there
and you know spending some time thinking
harder questioning even what we were
doing at the time I mean we were we
thought we were doing education and I
think we were
but where is it not giving you the value
we came up with a couple of things
and I remember I had just gone back from
from I just have some pictures that I
think otherwise just talking is boring
so you know you may notice there's no
text I remember that I had I had you
know just gone back from Chicago to
Bombay I knew some Marathi and so I
decided that one way to educate myself
was to spend some time in in the schools
and I started doing some work in math
because that didn't require as much
language and one of the things that I
realized was what did you start teaching
with now typically at least in India
perhaps in Yale I don't know you start
teaching with the curriculum and that
curriculum has been designed by
presumably people who know what has to
be taught and then you know and that
curriculum has attributes like textbooks
and exams and things like this and you
that's the framework that is
traditionally used for teaching and I
realized the in Bombay partly because I
couldn't do the maratti and secondly I
really wanted to understand you know
what children could do comfortably so
that then you could decide whether you
wanted to go ahead or to help the
children who were left behind I started
doing very simple math but because of
all these reasons and one of the early
realizations was that although we were
dealing at that time with grades 3 & 4
it almost was that you had to start with
preschool stuff and this is in Bombay
which even 20 years ago was quite
advanced and if you saw the schools in
Bombay infrastructure was quite fine
everybody was coming to school parents
had some education and yet kids seem to
be far behind where they were and so the
natural thing that we all do with kids
in our own homes is to start from where
the kids are and so that you build on
what you can do and then go towards you
know what you can't do and that's
essentially what we did when we kind of
took a step back a couple of other
things I think were very noteworthy at
the time if you start with things that
people can't do then the disinterest
comes in much earlier if you start with
things that kids can do and maybe push
them just a little bit harder
and if you do things for example one of
the things that we did and we still
continue to do is before which I should
have done with this group as well but I
know we have a time limit so I didn't is
you need to engage one-on-one a bit and
perhaps your chance samosas is a way of
doing that is that you engage a little
bit one-on-one so you get a sense and
maybe what should be did yesterday was
to enable that over dinner that you have
some personal engagement one-on-one and
get a sense of where kids are so that
then you can move up and the first thing
we noticed is although we love our
children in India just like everybody
loves their children everywhere we tend
to deal with them as groups so at home
you know there's a bunch of kids so you
have to get up on time and have to eat
on time and so on and so forth the
Troublesome ones you pay a little bit
more attention to but the average ones
are treated and in school you're treated
as a big group as well so even though
you know you spend time with kids it's
often very rare at least in school to
have spent time one-on-one with kids and
the one-on-one with kids actually gives
you a lot of insights into where they're
at and therefore building your
activities to take kids ahead is much
better grounded obviously if you have a
good sense of where kids are at and
don't pay as much attention to what
they're supposed to be doing so start
where they are you know go to where they
need to be the motivation for kids to
want to tell you where they're at comes
from when they see that you're actually
interested in them if they think that
your main purpose is to get the textbook
finished then they behave with you in
the same way so I think we you know I
think this is it's common sense but I
think it's also something that often in
education in India people have to be
reminded that each kid may be different
pay attention to them and if your
curriculum is good that it addresses
this question and if not that maybe you
have to think about what to do and so
you know one of the things that came out
of this exercise was that across the
country in I mean we were not as large
as we are today but we were quite large
there were at least two three hundred
people we decided that we need to figure
out what we
to do next if we want to get rid of this
uneasy feeling concretize it and then
look for solutions so our analysis was
that there were two or three fundamental
things that kids were still weak on one
was a lot of kids had gone through
several years of schooling but not able
to read as yet and what is not being
able to read mean if I had to have you
know everybody participate in a similar
conversation then they're not I mean I'm
I'm you know fast forwarding a little
bit but it meant that could you what
could you not read could you not even
read letters could you not read simple
words if you could read simple words
then what's the difference between the
simple words and a simple sentence and
then finally why do you read because you
want to read something so this is like a
story and so kid could you not read the
story and we found that even simplifying
it like this did two things one is you
could actually figure out what the
distribution of kids that you had and
the second was you could think about
what to do for taking kids from one step
to the other so this whole thing and
what would you want to give kids to read
we're just learning to read so all of
this I think that this this this one
piece of paper kind of captured a lot of
the learnings we had and I think this
was around 2001 or two that we decided
as a lot of the leadership team within
program maybe a couple of hundred people
that we should take a month out and see
what you can do once you understood the
problem then what do you do how long
does it take for a kid to move from
reading letters reading the story why a
month for no good reason other than
month is a month and everybody seems to
recognize it and it's also put some kind
of a time frame on it you know two
months just seems double of that so how
what we try to see what you can do at
one month and you know also people ask
you what are you doing so you know you
have something to you know you say so
from this game I think our a couple of
things one is we were able to while
reading may be a very complicated thing
but to be able to understand it for
yourself
and to be able to explain to parents
where is your child and all of this was
easy to do then secondly you could do
this in any language and so it didn't
need a lot of differences by language
the third is for everyone I think it's
helpful to have a goal so where are you
headed I mean the you know you could be
headed to reading the MA birth which you
know I hope all of you have because
you're highly educated people but at
least being able to read simple text
with some comprehension would be a
reasonable goal for reading so this also
helped you see the goal and I say see
the goal seriously because there were a
lot of parents who were not literate so
when they said what are you doing you
could say that the kids should be able
to get up to here and the visible here
you can see and if somebody reads it out
to you then you know kind of what level
is it is that the simple paragraph as
well was very important for us and we
didn't realize it at the time but when
you had kids start reading it we realize
they're actually reading a sentence is
sometimes harder than reading a set of
connected sentences and as you begin to
read like the second line the kids are
aware that this is all connected and so
they do what I later learned is called
psycholinguistic guessing which is to
guess ahead what that is we are often
told that you don't pretend does all
these things and you know they don't go
into depth and this is just decoding and
this is not reading with comprehension
and I think that people who criticize us
for that actually haven't sat a lot with
kids and watch them read because I
remember a little paragraph like that
that the paragraphs are very useful
because you feel like you've read
something but it's actually only four
lines so it gives you a sense of
accomplishment and at some point I'm
going to show you a short video which
also highlights that I think that kids
build on success so if you feel you can
do this then you try the next thing and
so it's important to give you stepping
stones which make you feel like you're
making progress and I remember coming up
with a paragraph and I'll tell you how
many people here understand Hindi plenty
of people so I apologize for those who
don't
it's quite simple Hindi so the paragraph
was
Shampoo poppin karate evening my father
comes home hard hooker kana cotton he
washes his hands and he eats dinner mas
a birthday card a he talks to my mother
paired so that there and then he goes to
sleep all four central all force lines
are quite straightforward there's no
complication in the spelling or the
grammar but child after child I remember
was hesitating on the third line I
couldn't understand why that should be
their voice would go down and finally
after I think the third or fourth kid I
said what's the matter and one of the
children said Papa mommy's about the
naked thing my dad doesn't talk to my
mom so I mean I think even listening to
their voice you realize that they were
thinking you know this is this is not
cool so I think that even listening to
things like this actually gave you a
sense not just off what is their ability
to read but what are they thinking how
are they going I have another example
that I always remember this was in
Bombay and the paragraph said
marikar ke saamne acknowledged a you
know there's a there's a whatever drain
in front of my house and almost I think
three of five kids read this and
everybody replace the word Nala with
gutter which to me is a very high level
of not only are you reading but you're
also replacing the word with what ought
to be the word there because that's the
word that's in common use so all of this
I think close observation of what the
kids were doing helped us to come up
with you know stuff that could really be
helpful and and useful and as a result
of that one month you know many things
happen one was that you realize that
there could be substantial progress in a
short period of time we didn't start
with small children I have to say that
we started with kids who had already
been at least seven or eight because
they are cognitively ready to do many
things they have also been they've had
some exposure to pricked whether they
can read or not and partly also because
there is an urgency by the time you're
that age to really move fast because the
actual curriculum is a lot further than
this
whereas
their young ones were just starting
school there is still still time so we
could see that even in a month a lot of
progress can be made and a lot of these
kind of instructional you know I mean
common-sense things came out of you know
two three hundred people doing this with
everybody with a bunch of kids actually
gives you a lot of information
I mean lot of experience on what needs
to be done so we had a I would say
instructional path forward about how do
you accelerate this problem because you
can now concretize the problem using
something like this and we have a
similar one for math and also with what
do you do about it so that it's not just
that you're saying that there's a
problem you also have some kind of a
solution that you could propose but a
couple of other things happened that we
had not expected so for example some of
the work that we were doing was not
happening inside the school we did some
in Sweden wherever it was convenient
sometimes inside the school sometimes
outside the school very interestingly
and we felt this right from the
beginning of proton that the outside
school space is often not given as much
value in education for some reason we
think the stuff that happens inside a
classroom is really important and the
stuff inside the classroom is often
highly structured as you know you know
we sit in rows and columns we do that in
primary school we do it at Yale there
are certain you know frameworks that
seem to come into place as soon as
you're inside the classroom in an
educational setting when you're outside
it's really a big mess and as a result
of the big mess a lot of people can act
of their own accord and one of the
things that happened is people asked us
what are you doing now inside the school
very rarely does anybody ask you what
you're doing because it's very obvious
what you're doing your teaching but
outside the school people want to know
what are you doing and I think that that
was a very important thing for us
because we realize that if you want to
carry a lot of people along then it's
important to say what you're doing and
have people question you you know there
is a
a particular event that happened to be
and I wished at the time that there were
no cellphones then so you could have
taken quick videos and then used it in
talks forever but this was a as we began
to work in rural areas we would do what
we call a village report card the
village report card is essentially
exactly what I just described that you
need to understand where fields are
before suggesting any pot you know for
the village and so basically you went
around the village and you started using
that simple tool to get people to engage
to see could kids read and you know do
you go to school and can you read and
can you do basic math and after doing it
for a little while actually it's spread
straightforward so a lot of other people
begin to help and there is conversation
that begins to happen you know there's
conversation at the higher level which
is the adults there's conversation among
the kids and so on and again that
generates a lot of talk around what is
the issue if indeed there is an issue I
actually did time at once that in a
place like u P or Bihar it often takes
took 45 minutes for the discussion to
start and then end at a point where you
can actually move forward and so the
discussion starts with the British I
don't know if there any British people
in this room please don't take it
personally but it starts with how the
British Shrek does so okay that that
happened quite a while back so then you
come down to you know Neru and then to
Indra Randy then to blah blah blah and
to the Chief Minister then too so you
know it takes time for the blame to be
attributed to everyone and then finally
you come down to you know you blame the
teachers if you're a parent you blame
the teachers if you're a teacher you
blame the parents and when you have no
one else to blame you blame the children
because you say oh I got the kid ready
and he went too you know but he's not
learning right and the only person you
don't blame in all of this is of course
yourself because everybody else is to
blame so you go down that whole route
and you know once you reach the point
that you know everybody accepts that yes
people are going to school but they're
having difficulty learning then you have
many choices one choices do nothing I
mean you're not compelled to act you can
just let things be and the other is to
do something and once you get to the
point of do something then you can
actually you know we could then say okay
here are a couple of
things that you can do because it is
important if you want to bring about
some change that there is some more
buy-in and you don't leave this all to
the people who are supposed to do it
because the people who are supposed to
do it clearly are not able to do it
which is why this it's creating the
problem and so these village report
cards I think were very useful because
it helped us realize that it this it's
not just enough for some people to
realize as a problem and create some
information that you can act on but that
you need to really spread out the
ability to see the problem and then also
think about how the problem could be
solved so this one leg inside and one
leg outside the education system I think
was important because often the outside
asked many more questions that helped
you to figure out how you can do things
that could be potentially you know
brought inside so if I come back to
Johanna but when I started my story
that's the district magistrate and this
is his crew I said to him that I think
by this time we were just a few years
ahead of him and I said I think the
problem that you faced what are the
reasons could be what are we expecting
children to do in the classroom and I
gave him a you know a briefer version of
work what I've told you and I said you
know but we I'm happy to talk and I you
know I was I was in Bihar already and I
said that you know maybe in a couple of
days you know we can come down and can
have a chat so I arrived literally two
days later I went to his office and he
already had taken some of the thoughts
and implemented so he had gone he had
had with his team they had been to about
five schools and they had made their own
little test which was basically a grade
level test and figured out that the kids
were way below where they needed to be
so by the time I arrived he had I think
he had felt the problem he had gone down
a path of kind of trying to understand
it and you know what we reached his
office he was ready to act
he now needed to understand what to do
so his first reaction was to say so you
are proximal so why don't you bring your
people in restrain my teachers and you
know let's get rid of the problem now
800 schools every
school may have at least three or four
teachers it's a substantial number of
teachers so I said well you know that's
not going to work a we don't have people
like that and B is you realize the
problem you want to solve it but you are
one person and you are you know whole
lot of other people so they need to hit
me pull this cap up okay disrobe so we
said how about the same process that
you've gone through can we have some of
your guys actually because in the end
you have a system and the system has
people at every layer if you want to
solve the problem just the guy the top
feeling like you need to solve the
problem is maybe necessary but certainly
not sufficient so how do we work with so
he said what do you need and I said I
need a month but I need two hours a day
I don't need the whole month I need two
hours a day from people who are one
level up from the teachers and so what
we did was that they took two blocks
they had about five blocks they took two
blocks and the people at the block level
who are above twenty schools are called
cluster coordinators in the system some
of whom you can see here so you I want
to put the picture so you can see what
who these people are the while they are
in the education system in a large part
of India especially in North Indian they
also run the elections they are the ones
who do the electoral rolls they are the
ones who so they are very key pieces of
our whole entire democratic structure
they do have a day job which is to be in
school and to help the school system and
so what we did essentially was to say
that I need a couple of days three or
four days first with them to orient them
about our way of thinking exactly that's
that's who runs our country at the
ground level even in southern states at
this level above the level of the
teacher they are not that many women
because you're technically your job is
to visit twenty schools which means some
amount of running around to things in I
mean going into slight detail because
yeah
you know how do you then influence you
know what to do but how do you influence
the system two things the first day they
came we said okay if I go into an
average school in your district how many
children will I find there today can you
give me a number
and they gave numbers and the numbers
were all around 60 65 70 72 75 percent
and then we said if I go to an average
school and I show you the little tool
that I had how many kids in 3rd 4th or
5th grade will be able to read the
simple story and they put down some
numbers then we went out of the building
to about 10 schools nearby and this was
not far from the district headquarters
so presumably those schools have some
some advantages and we came back and you
had to put luck next to the number that
you'd put down what you actually saw the
attendance numbers were very close to
the reality because they had been
looking at it a lot and so they are a
very good sense of what attendance was
like exactly like their boss had the
learning numbers were way off everybody
heavily overestimated what children
would know and these were people who
were actually the schools a lot and so
once they saw what that variation was
they were way more open to wanting to do
something about it and again I think
again and again we feel it unless you
feel the problem no day at least in
India I think until you feel the problem
data doesn't change your mind
it's still your first-hand experience
that there is really a problem and then
what we asked them to do was you know
that what we had learned to do and to do
it for you know 20 days or so because we
know that in 20 or 30 days there's
actually quite a big change if you do it
and once that layer was done I remember
going to a school at this time when one
of the key one of these guys was
teaching you can see exactly what age
they are they've been teaching for a
long time they feel they know everything
and yet when they were teaching they
discovered that a couple of things one
is that kids you know progress really
quickly one of these men I remember it
was a school where there was just rice
fields all around and he was the only
guy who was you know teaching and he
said to me I don't know what's going on
usually kids go home after lunch
these kids are not going they're still
hanging around I don't know I mean he
kind of said it and very you know this
believing kind of way so I said I wonder
what's going on and we got up and I was
joking and we looked out of the window
and he came with me and he started
looking outside was nothing outside so I
finally said perhaps it's because of you
and he looked shocked because he had
come through I think an entire
professional life being blamed for many
things but really rarely being able to
take the credit for some big change that
he was doing so this whole process I
think led us to many more learnings one
was that you have to feel the problem
you have to yourself feel that you can
solve the problem and once you've done
that then you're ready to be a
missionary except you're sometimes very
nervous of talking to other people about
it so you need some more help in saying
that I have done it and you can do it
too because we are so used to listening
to instructions and not communicating it
in that way at least in education I
think we do it very well in a lot of
other fields but in education you are
used to being following a curriculum
following a guide following somebody
else's instructions that you're your own
initiative and your own motivation
somehow has been you know lost in the
whole case so long long story this was
what the janabat story looked like that
in about you know over 200 schools that
they did this in thirds where standard 3
4 & 5 there was only 30 percent children
who could actually read even the
paragraph and this is after spending you
know if you think about 5 years of
school and 200 days every day that's a
thousand days of being in school this is
what we were able to produce and a large
number almost 60 percent who were not
able to read even words which are
counted for why you want to leave school
after lunch and play cricket because
there everybody can perform and
everybody has a role and nobody tells
you you can't do it and with the lead
taken by the guys that you saw this is
the kind of improvement that was
possible they with some interruptions
and so on they did about 70 days and in
70 days even if you can't see the
numbers you can see how the read reduced
and the green increased
I have a little film which I don't know
if we we can see it but I can send it to
you it's on the desktop just to see what
I mean I I think it's it's a very short
one let's see it's called
yes yes yeah you need the sound oh you
need to hear her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is 40 50 days and I think that
apart from the fact that she can read we
didn't fix the sound I think it's the
sound of her I mean she sits traitor
she talks louder and the this film
didn't catch but there was a beautiful
smile at the end of it I think that
apart from reading I think a lot of
these other things that happen are
fundamental to giving the child the
belief that you know they they can do
stuff I'm gonna move quickly now because
I know we have we need to leave time for
so very quickly a couple of just
stepping back and looking at it so what
is so different about all this what is
it doing that was not being done before
and if I think about the core work that
we started with what happens between the
learner and whoever is the instructor I
think there are a couple of quite
different issues from what happens in
her to go to classroom one is there's a
clear goal the goal is that I'm going to
make sure that you have these I'm gonna
help you acquire basic foundational
skills which will then help you to move
ahead both on your own as well as with
others if you can read and you can
understand and if you have the
confidence to say I didn't understand
that actually takes you quite far
because while I'm calling this a great
two level text most of these kids once
they get to that Nancy stage can almost
read most simple things and if along
with that they have the confidence to
say I didn't understand this can you
explain it I think these are skills that
go quite quite far in terms of how this
is all organized your
grouped for this bi-level rod not by
your grade and your group by level only
temporarily because you move quite
quickly from one level to the next so
that by the end of it is very fuel P
kids left in any lower group so you can
taste the progress the progress is very
quick
you're not slotted into what you know
where you're supposed to be you can move
through that a lot of the work happens
in groups very interactively you help
each other quite a bit and I think that
from the classroom level if I go up to
how this change came about I think a lot
of our traditional way of doing things
have to be left behind and so if you
want a big change particularly in
something like this I think you have to
be willing to let go of a lot of the
scaffolding that has actually organized
our basic school system and be willing
to take the jump and move you know and
move further is there resistance to all
of this so I just pulled out some of the
recent articles from the press and you
know there are many more and to me it's
very interesting as to who criticises
you and why some criticisms come from
the pedagogy establishment and that's
been actually the old criticisms that
have happened between the us er as well
as this approach that we are using and
more recently I see that there is
criticisms coming from those who are for
example BCG not a traditional actor in
in education but now they're you know
working a lot and I think that looking
at criticisms looking at the resistance
it's very interesting because it gives
you a sense of where is this disruption
actually affecting people and again
these are just questions actually I have
two people like yourselves who are
probably you know have a bigger you know
analytical view of so I think a lot of
criticism comes from what is what is the
assumptions that you have that are being
challenged and what is your kind of
theory of change of what do you think
will bring about this reform and you
know I've tried to kind of bucket that
into four or five major ones one set of
criticisms comes from the fact
of from from a point of view which says
that unless you have all the inputs in
place you can't start talking about
outcomes so you need enough teachers you
need enough materials you need enough
you know training you need sufficient
and enough of a variety of inputs before
you can say that I need to have outcomes
like learning and that often you know it
is a strong point of view once a right
to education law came into being there's
a whole set of people who believe that
everything that law has to happen and
it's only after that that you can have
conversations like these then there's a
second group of people I think who
believe that and I think that that I
don't disagree with any of these the
second group of people who believe that
you know teachers are not capable and
therefore you need to have far longer
training better teachers you know all
kinds of things to do with teaching
because unless the people who are
delivering this or for higher quality
you're not going to get the outcomes
that you want and therefore that this is
a long run process you need to build
institutions which are going to change
this basic you know quality of teachers
before you can go ahead then there is I
think a third which I would say is a to
me a techno managerial kind of approach
which says that the reason you have poor
outcomes is because the system doesn't
function well and for the 6/10 system to
function well you need a lot of you know
push for good functioning so biometrics
for when you come into school monitoring
apps who are going to make sure that
you're doing the stuff that you're
supposed to be doing maybe better
teacher deployment systems and so on
often there's a technology solution do
these and once those are all in place
and the system functions then you'll see
much better outcomes so you know you
have a poor sister why is a system for
inputs artwork the quality of whoever's
in it is poor the systems don't work
well and there is maybe a fourth one
which says there's no incentives that
for us any one of us to do things we
need proper incentives we need
accountability and these structures are
missing you know you become a teacher
your teacher for life and so on and so
forth and probably we fall into a fifth
category
says that there is a structural problem
and the structural problem is that the
core of it is where the learning and the
teaching happens and the expectations
around that are actually wrong
are there economists in this audience
okay so Lant Pritchett who many of you
may know has a wonderful paper and the
reason I like the paper a lot is that
the title tells everything you don't
even have to read the paper because it
title gives you and more economists
should write papers like that and the
paper is called the negative
consequences of over-ambitious
curriculum and I think that we are
certainly an example of that because if
you look at this situation and we've
done we work a lot with state
governments in different places there
was one particular study that was done
by Japan which is interesting the whole
year long teachers worked with kids and
using some of the methods that we are
talking about but still within the
bounds of the curriculum and then in the
summer that year we were able to
persuade Bihar government to say that
teachers will work with the kids but we
put the curriculum aside and we aim for
the kinds of goals that we are talking
about here and the same teachers were
able to produce far higher results in
that one month in the summer holidays
than in the whole school year what was
different the teachers were the same the
children were the same the difference
was I think that the pressure of the
curriculum had been moved away and so I
think that a lot of in understanding the
resistance and the criticisms it is
really what is the theory of change and
how willing are you to go down the
logical you know steps to take you from
how you understand the problem - and to
many of these the critics I often feel
like it would be helpful to have a
conversation to say where do you see the
beginning of the problem you may not
like my solution and I think that's
perfectly valid but where do you see the
beginning and where do you see the
logical next few steps and how and where
are you bringing about this change that
that that you think is this important so
just just going a little bit further you
know right now where we are we see that
this issue of learning is maybe thanks
to us er which I
mention that the to let you saw is
basically you know is has become the
tool for measuring learning and in India
and at least done by us the report is
called the annual status of Education
report the 13th one came out this year
and it has played a big contribution in
moving the discussion from just
schooling to schooling and learning and
so you know working with a lot of state
governments we can see that you're on
here state governments are moving
towards wanting to make a big change the
challenge seems to be how do you sustain
that momentum year on year on year so
that it becomes part of the
institutional you know way in which
schools function how can you have this
catch-up mechanism as part of the system
rather than as an add-on that comes in
as some kind of a reform effort but I
think where I'd like to leave off and
where I think there are big questions
and some young people asked me this last
night as well is that why is all of this
not a bigger political agenda and you
know while this is something that you
know I mean if you think about India's
having 250 million children in school
and if you believe what I'm showing you
and what the Assessor report says that
at least half the kids are way behind
where they are to be that is a huge
number that's a hundred and some million
children some of whom are in everyone's
home so why is it not a bigger agenda
for you know at the bureaucratic level
at the policy level is one thing but why
is it not a bigger political agenda and
I have to say that I don't have answers
for that you see flashes of you know
Nitish Kumar in his early days Manish
Sisodia currently you see you see and
neither I I think these are individual
priorities that people have been able to
surface but it doesn't seem to seep into
the parties that they belong to and
therefore there is clearly something
that going from the individual to a
bigger agenda to actually entering when
these people become powerful for it to
stay on it has to move beyond individual
and we can't see why that is the case I
want to just leave you with a couple of
questions one is that say for example I
spent some time in Himachal and I know
somebody here has he may have some
insights in detail discussions with very
senior people in Himachal one of them
said it very well he said that every
single legislative you know elected
state person to the state legislature
has visited his office every one of them
has had an agenda for education and the
agenda tends to be teacher transfer and
not a single person he said he explained
to me you are talking to me about
learning outcomes and how important they
are
you are saying it some of my teachers
say it but not a single elected official
has ever raised with me the fact that he
wants the schools and his constituency
to have higher learning so why should I
act because it doesn't seem to be a and
I I frankly had no answer for it and
later on thinking about it I think you
know I wondered two or three things and
I would love to have some discussion on
that you know is education or health
still in India seen as a private problem
to be solved by private and individual
ways rather than by collective I had a
an incident again that reminds me of you
no way to answer this this was a group
of mothers in a village in John poor
district in yupi and I remember asking
these moms you know who school is ETA
Kiska schooler so they said yes our
curry school this is a government school
so I said who is government and they
started laughing there saying you know
the district magistrate is government
the block official is government so I
said so where does the government get
its money and their point was Jairaj
Carter has kept a space out of that
those who rule have money so I tried to
explain and I know I went back and I
thought I should have taken much better
public finance courses because clearly
I'm not making any so I said but how
does how do they get the money and they
said they have money otherwise they
would not be ruling so I try to explain
now okay when you buy a bus ticket you
know part of this would be don't buy
elastic it reaches go in the bus okay
okay yeah when you buy biscuits we buy
you know I mean none of this seemed to
work so finally at least this was you
could say that every cellphone that you
have you know you're paying I mean it
just seems so circuit is to say that you
go to get your you know prepaid whatever
charge and that somehow goes into the
coffers of the government seemed like
very far away so basically a government
cut school and the government should
come and see and make sure that things
happen for my own children I don't
expect anything from the school if I had
money I would put them into a tuition
class and then he would make progress
this seemed to be the framework with
which you were moving so how do you make
the fact that you know we are all paying
money I mean everybody's paying money to
make education happen and yet you're not
getting what you ought to how does that
become and then add to that the fact
that regardless people often ask me so
how is this government versus the last
government and I feel they're quite
similar frankly because they've all been
obsessed with IMS and IITs and things
like this and perhaps this is also an
obsession that we have with excellence
rather than at some level with equity
that makes it to be this so just to end
with really an open question that I
think that where we started our work
more or less we're still right there is
how does citizens and governments really
come into this picture and really for
any big change to happen perhaps it has
to be a large number of citizens who
really believe that it's time for change
and that is what will push you know the
whatever we call the government to make
a change so I'll stop there and I hope
you'll help me answer some of these
questions
[Applause]
so I would say then a big question is
measurement right and the process that
we went through to say you know in some
countries like in Kenya you have a
primary school leaving exam so that's a
place where you can see perhaps you know
what the outcomes are in India we don't
have it till the 10th so therefore you
know a lot of you may leave school by
then you may have very good 10th grade
results because everybody who could have
potentially got til there are leaving
so the assert type of measurement which
starts quite you know we basically use
this simple measurement from first grade
onwards and people criticize us saying
that such as easy test why are you
giving it to kids in eighth grade but
there are still 30 25 30 percent kids
out there who can't do it
so the Assessor kind of measurement has
is used now in quite a few countries in
Africa and the answer to your question
varies so Kenya is kind of little bit
better than us if use in Pakistan
Pakistan is exactly like us
it's variations of course across in
different parts of Africa of Pakistan
francophone Africa is a lot worse and
for example if you say that in India we
have 50%
fifth grade who can't read or who can
read
whichever way in Mali that number is 10%
and so I think that part of the
francophone results being really bad is
French because at least here we are
being assessed in our own local language
whereas there it's you know the medium
of instruction is French this kind of
measurement which is done in this very
simple way is actually you know raising
this kind of question in Africa as well
and I think globally the fact that if
you wait and if you do grade level
measurements you may be missing out and
a huge big issue early on is at least
now being talked you know talked about I
think their problems are also quite I
mean there's somewhat different problems
for example schools are sometimes very
large Nigeria there was some of my
colleagues move into a school which have
2,000 children in a primary school and
so that has you know several other
problems so fewer schools but much
larger schools and so the you know what
do you do there but I think that this
absent is a problem I actually don't buy
it because one is what is the reason for
absenteeism and if you look at even if
you look at studies in India if every
teacher takes all the leave that they're
entitled to which why should they not
because they are entitled to it you
would get a 25% rate like you have now
so either you have to change the
conditions under which you can take
leave and then blame it it's very easy
to blame teachers everybody does it and
I personally feel that we have enough
evidence to show that given realistic
goals and given adequate support
teachers can actually do a really good
job if you give them a really idiotic
goal and give them no support or I
wouldn't go to school either you know
frightened so if you really feel like we
have to work with teachers I have to
really work with them you know you have
to have these kind of cluster guides
visit your schools all the time but job
is implementing we are with them in
implementing of basic learning
improvement and the unions are up in
arms because somebody is visiting your
school every second day so the good
schools really like it and the beds I
mean the hard-working teachers love it
and the less hard-working teachers don't
like it yeah presumably less
hard-working teachers have more time to
be in the Union or have more direct
connections or see
to be able to have political action much
faster than the hard-working ones so I
think there are I'm sure there are
differences but I think some of the
common problems and the land issue I
think is common everywhere I think it's
only in Western countries which have had
school universal schooling for much
longer that the curriculum expectations
the capabilities to deliberate the
understanding of what has to be done is
much closer to each other than there is
in countries which have higher
aspirations but low capability to
deliver I mean Vietnam apparently is a
great example where they have really
done the primary education quite well
where they have really I think there was
an equity push probably you know in the
last 20 years which has ensured that at
least Basic Education is strong if your
basic foundational education is good you
can go quite far so I think paying
attention to that early on you know has
perhaps work there I I don't know enough
about you know inner workings of those
countries to
[Music]
I think that's not enough
I think obviously you need to have yes
but so so I would say that if I look at
a traditional typical classroom in India
well you know what does a fifth grade
teacher do and what is the fifth grade
teachers are expected to do they are
expected to take the fifth grade
textbook and start from chapter one and
go up to chapter 24 and finish that in
12 months that is what a teacher is
expected to do a fifth grade classroom
if you saw the Johanna bad numbers
probably has 10 or 15% kids who are
getting what you're saying so I think a
regular teacher attendance would benefit
that 15 percent tremendously and really
not make much of a difference to the
others unless the teacher was given a
different goal to do and I think from
Bihar numbers you can see I mean from I
mean we we've done quite a lot of work
in Bihar I think that given realistic
goals and support for firstly teacher
attendance will be higher if you stop
doing certain things such as having
trainings during the school year we are
continues to do that but the village for
example does most of its trainings in
the holidays so that during school time
teachers are in school and not away in
training secondly if you stop deploying
teachers for other work such as sensors
such as I mean the the the right to
education law says you can take teachers
away for disaster for elections
and for census for example be hard at
one stage had to state elections in the
same year well you may as well shut the
schools down and let everybody play
cricket maybe we'll have some you know
more World Cup players and not bother
you know with the so I think there is a
lot to be done and it's a mystery to me
why teachers unions don't agitate for
some of these things on that maybe
because you get paid extra to do census
you get other patronage benefits from
handling elections locally and so on but
I do think that the same teachers with
support can do a lot and you know to be
stingy about support means that you
really don't want the teachers to work
and making words groups of children
drawing with chalk on the floor and I
really felt that not having tables and
chairs was really an advantage on the
board and what each of the kids really
was geared towards giving them a sense
of accomplishment and I also saw groups
of children graduated from that and
sitting because these were kids who they
were writing essays and they were doing
things together so there was a lot of
emphasis on
helping each other and the classroom the
teachers looked really enthusiastic and
I think that they also sensed that they
were making an impact on the children
and I think that sort of you know gave
them encouragement to proceed further so
I have to say that the curriculum
particularly is what struck me and
something that helped the kids get a
sense of confidence that they could
master so this is really nice yes all
right okay okay someone else's kids and
they were quite busy doing what they
were doing you're not paying that much
attention so this this what she's
talking about is actually a massive
upscaling of what I talked about in
janabat
the entire state of U P is trying to do
this and there was huge skepticism and
led by me that you P would ever be able
to actually and yet same teachers the
much-maligned teachers are actually a
partly because the layer above them
actually did all of this stuff
themselves and were able to I think
guide them I mean we have to still wait
and see there's another month left of
how far they can reach by the 30th of
April but so far it has been actually
quite remarkable that a very what should
I say sluggish system like you P that
has had nothing on quality education for
10-15 years is able to rise and without
much what shall I say it's not a high
priority for the Chief Minister I asked
one of the district magistrates there
you know he's just been transferred
after the
we'll announce he was the district
magistrate of Ribery Lee and so we were
visiting invest in the district and
somebody said you know DM sub is very
interested in education so I went to
meet him so I said why are you so
interested and he said well everybody
has a personal interest and I actually
think that this primary education stuff
is good so I asked him what do we have
to do to have 75 guys like you be
interested and he pointed to the
photograph behind him and he said well
you'll have to say that so I said is he
not saying it in he said nah but despite
all that that's why it's not necessary
that the very top but you know changes I
mean I think that to me
I really see the like the theories of
change that I describe I think all of
those are needed it's not like you can
do you know why should you not have
enough teachers why should the system
not function there ought to be
accountability there ought to be you
know longer run deeper capability
building of teachers all of those are
important but I think that what she said
is very key you need to feel progress
you need to feel that you're making a
difference and I think the only way to
feel that in the school system is for
children to progress you can do a lot of
systemic reform but it doesn't hit the
kids so you can have for example much
better procurement systems you know it
probably saves the taxpayer you know
good money but it doesn't get to that to
me the core is what happens in the
classroom between the teacher and the
kids because if I go back
my first thing about the discouraged
teacher and the disappointed parent and
the disinterested child I think that
whatever you do has to hit that first
once that changes which is what she's
describing then many things become
possible and even ride the wave of you
know whatever progress or again to do
many more things so I think that you
know if I compare what happened in
Rajasthan in the last couple of years I
think they tried many things but a lot
of them were management type things
again I'm not saying they're not
important but I don't think they
filtered into the classroom so you had
you consolidated schools I think that's
a that was needed but in consolidating
schools if you had been able to link it
so people would feel that because the
schools were consolidated my child is
doing better and it's visible to
everybody in the village and everybody
in the village is actually not educated
but I can still feel it I think that
that reform would have gone further what
I think Sonia is doing is that number
one they pay a lot of attention to
parents and a mistake that a lot of
education reform movements do is that
they feel you can fix the system you
know I hear a lot of talk in the jargon
these days about systems before I mean
system maybe they like me Anna so you
worry far more I can a what the
thickness of room and it was made me or
at whatever I mean parents if you if
parents don't feel there is something
happening to the kids and I think
attendance is actually a very good proxy
because why are the kids going off and
playing cricket like what the hell is
are you doing in school is really boring
I mean you know why are you all sitting
here you know presume is gonna be a good
dinner but other than that there has to
be you know you've gotta feel that
you're part of this whole picture so
system reforms I think I really needed
but they often don't focus on the real
you know matter and so you know Sisodia
has paid a lot of attention to parents
he'd also they've done I mean I think
they they're handling the core but
they're also handling exactly the three
pieces that I think they're handling
teachers they're handling parents and
they're handling you know what needs to
happen between teachers and children and
they've had a lot of resistance exactly
the same kind of resistance partly you
know we feel the same way
and when you're getting attacked both
from the right of the left you know
you're doing something right yeah I need
a moderator here okay we go to the back
of the class
[Laughter]
so the skeptical one I think we should
answer first so yes we have been doing
so ah sir has been a I would say a now a
part of the landscape for you know over
ten years and every five years we have a
big discussion about whether it should
stop the first five years there was a
very strong feeling and you know ah sir
is carried out by a different
organization in every single district in
India so the design is done by Pritam
but the implementation is done by local
groups and there is a quite a lot of you
know quality checks on a big problem was
when the teacher training colleges the
diets they are called in India the
government teacher training colleges
wanted to participate because it does
that compromise the citizen aspect of uh
sir and after a lot of discussion within
we decided that if an organization wants
to do it as long as they implement it
well why should they not come forward
last assert two hundred and sixty diets
half the diets of India it did us
sometimes full states and these are the
trainees are going to be teachers and
the way that some of the principles
explain it is that the institution does
a lot for what you're supposed to do
inside the school you know prepared
teachers for that but never teach them
to engage with communities or parents
and also provides that so one is who
does it the who is many thousands of I
mean there are five hundred different
partners who do it every year the second
is that yes we do learning programs
should we which one should we stop doing
and I think that stopping we are not
doing a sir every other year partly
because you know you have to raise a lot
of my
also for I mean it's compared to other
surveys actually it's not that expensive
but you still have to raise about you
know a certain amount of money and you
know just a years gap seems to be fine
you know you if you leave three years
then they may be a big change
so should we stop doing the learning
initiatives but that seems what would be
ideal is if I think if the measurement
of literacy in the census could actually
be a real measurement and not if the NSS
would take on the role we need to pass
this on to someone who's not us we are
not able to find that someone yet and I
think that state-by-state there could be
but it requires a lot of persistence to
want to do us a year after year I mean
it's like the largest survey that's done
in I don't know in India for sure
probably globally as well the real
question which you didn't ask is that
there is skeptics who say that if the
program works with the state the results
will be good these skeptics clearly
don't look at evidence we work with many
states for many years and there are many
states that are not doing well where we
work and there are several states where
we don't work we're doing well so the
counterfactual is you know quite quite
quite strong on the teaching at the
right level I try to give a little
flavor of it I mean fundamentally how do
you deal with the fact that a lot of
kids are behind and you want to bring
them up quickly and you want to do it as
part of the system so one is what are
the instructional activities to do which
you know I could go into but you know
there are four or five quite simple
things some of which she described and
the other is the measurement part
because during whether when the
government is implementing it even in a
massive state like yupi even in a period
of three months the baseline which is
exactly that tool is helpful in grouping
kids so you and and it's not just a
group thing it's that the teacher now
knows every kid in the class and knows
what they can do so that information is
not captured in the data that
information is in her instructional mind
to be able to use as to who will be in
what group and what they will do and the
second is that you need to you know
build when there is a clear goal I think
the movement towards the goal people
actually really like the measurement
because it makes you feel that you
come some way and it's been only a month
but you actually made progress because
you're used to a system where a whole
year goes by and you may not have made
much progress so I think the measurement
is is an important but the measurement
is very simple but so it it plays a part
in that and then I think that if you
think about what kids need to get ready
for and you're going to exist in that
system I'm not saying that beyond this
first round of big building foundational
skills we have some great ideas of what
to do next you want to create the habit
among kids of working with each other
because that help will come from each
other then you want to give the kids a
bit you hit upon I don't know if you're
a education person but you hit upon some
very key you want to give kids the
motivation to want to go ahead I think
you learn when you're motivated you want
and the motivation often comes from
progress so I think there's a lot of you
know basic psychology here at work that
if you get give people teachers or
parents or children the feeling that
you're moving ahead the chances that you
move ahead as way higher if you give
people the expectation that everybody
can learn our systems don't do that our
system says some people will come first
others will come last but if you give
and that's where I think the equity idea
comes if you feel like you are your your
bedrock is that you can do it or when
people actually do I think there is now
a lot of research which shows that if
you expect high people do high if you
expect low then you know you may as well
play cricket I mean I'm all for cricket
by the way no I'm using it in a bad way
and I think that and it has to be a
methodology that everybody can use it's
not so you know highfalutin that only
some people with lots of training can do
it what you saw was you pee teachers
doing it village volunteers can do it I
mean your grandma can do it if you know
it's it's not such a big thing and the
other advantage is that while say for
some things in health you really do need
inputs and you need expertise I mean
every village in India has some people
who are educated so if you give if we
give you know 30 days of our time for a
year or two I think India could be a
different place and I certainly feel
even the skeptics have to accept that
if you have something that you're
rolling with what are you waiting for
[Music]
so my view on that is that if it's a law
and you know let's presume I mean you
know we don't listen to many laws but if
it's law it should take it seriously
then it's Alanna so whatever we felt
before it became a law we should have
done not to make it a law but now it's a
law so how do you operate within the
confines of the law to have you know and
yeah and I think it's still an open case
it's a law but if you go state by state
and ask exactly how you're interpreting
it people are waiting and therefore this
is a very important moment because if
you can come up with some good ideas at
this stage and get people to implement
some of those so 5th and 8th to have an
exam ok what exam how exam who will do
the exam that's all still quite open
detail okay
when will you detail will you detail
instantly will you detail after three
months when will you have the exam and I
we again he machen it so happened that
the Assessor report was going to be
released by the Himachal chief minister
and chief ministers like to release a
report when the report does well and
when the report doesn't do well they say
over something called Bukhari okay but
you know we are very open about it you
know so that's fine and their report was
supposed to be released in the morning
but full Lama happened two days before
so the Chief Minister went to the
funeral of there was one one soldier
from
so as a result we had like three hours
in one room with everybody from the
Education Department and the minister so
we had a lot of discussions so I asked
him this question what he's gonna do and
they said what do you think we should do
so I said if that mattered I'll write a
whole thesis and if you tell me what
you're planning and essentially it
boiled down to all these are still
variables when is the exam what is the
exam are you gonna give one chance to
chances to chances when and my point to
them was so you this these kids had a
problem I mean the kid is 88 10 years
old so clearly the kid couldn't have a
problem the problem that has been
imposed on the kid has been done by you
guys do you accept it they were like
well yes okay so then you have to do
something before you can detain them so
can we come up with something between
the first exam and the second exam that
actually gives you a chance and if after
all of that and if the kid comes then
would it be fair so if the kid fails
twice is there something more that needs
to be done with the kid is there some
kind of so I feel like there is a I
think anybody working on education in
India today who I mean I personally
don't think detention I mean yes you can
detain my point before it became a law
would be I'm all for detention but not
of the kid so you can start with the
Education Minister and detain everybody
else I'm glad I actually have I mean I
don't say that in public but now that it
is a law how can you play with the
framework to maximize the opportunity
for the child to get help and maybe this
will make the children get a big
remedial or whatever catch up those that
was not available otherwise so I think
it's a very exciting space and you know
people should play with this space so
that is something concrete and useful
comes out of it and not just just you
know put all the kids you know in jail
or whatever they want to do
my god is there anybody here who hasn't
worked in the restaurant welcome okay
well that study never got off the ground
I was extremely disheartening that we've
invested all this time in the state that
it didn't take off and I just want to
give like with engineering a chance
how does one keep the energy to keep him
change so to see that I'm not a member
of our show okay so you know our
experience is likely because we value
button very much we love you of material
the excellent
my experience is slightly different you
know visit villages and the smaller
villages we might have a school a single
school one teacher grades 1 to 3 and the
teacher may or may not larger villages
may have so there are large parts of or
you visit certain areas and they'll tell
you no one in this district of our
spines yes SSE yeah so we just don't
enter those subjects we never take those
subjects I'm just wondering what do you
think the scale of the problem is if we
think you know we need education as a
senior agency for all children in India
universal quality education what's the
scale of this probably you know how big
yeah so what is that I think your first
question the the government work is far
larger and has problems like she's
saying and it goes up and down there is
instability but I think it is also
important to have some laboratories of
your own where you can continuously keep
refining changing you know coming up
with better newer things and so we have
let's say you know given the diversity
of India and the size you need to have a
substantial laboratory if you want to
stay alive with you know what is the
problem what's the next problem and you
know keep a kind of an rnd going so we
have that and the learning camps are
part of that but if you look at where
our bulk of our I mean our currently our
teams are divided half and half because
when we do it ourselves each person has
five villages and they will do whatever
they need to do for five villages
including trying to figure out which is
the next piece that needs to be handed
and more or less where we are headed
right now is to say step back if you are
able to do early childhood well the
first one or two years in school and
carry parents along can that then
sustain higher because part of it is
parents can't help what parents can't
identify and therefore if you do the
right I mean if you do foundations well
so we are working now again in the early
childhood space partly ourselves but
largely with the ICDs system because
there you see that although there is
health and nutrition the preschool
education gets really left behind so how
do you you know how do you also bring in
some wallah knee because it's easier at
some level to help at that stage and
then with the government's I think that
you know you have to the problem with
the government work is not working with
the government the problem with the
government work is us having the support
to be able to field teams for a long
time to work
the resources of support are important I
mean that's partly why I'm in America
I've come here to do this talk but I'm
also here to I mean not here but in the
US to raise funds three sources of
support that we have one is corporate
you know Indian corporates who now with
the CSR law have to give money second is
foundations usually international
foundations whose interest is now moving
largely to sub-saharan Africa because
you know we are putting I don't know we
are shooting down satellites we are
going to the you know space and all this
so you know why can't we Kelly India has
money if you have any fancy weddings you
know so you know people people don't
want to fund him India anymore and the
third is for up for us is a you know
individuals individuals usually Indian
diaspora now off these three types of
funds funding our direct work corporates
love to do especially if it's close to
their factories or their areas of
interest and those tend to be on in
certain parts of India Karnataka Pune
everybody wants to fund in Pune well
Sudan doesn't need anymore help they're
doing it fine you know ma rashtra go
down you know Coimbatore but nobody
wants to go to like Jharkhand large
parts of us I mean
rest of the country Himachal which is a
way people don't I mean it's there's no
corporate interest there because it's
very it's so individuals you know who
live here don't have great I mean don't
have great faith in the government
functioning they may have great faith in
certain political parties but not in the
functioning of the government for
obvious reasons so the real challenge
for us is to maintain and be able to
ride I mean the Karnataka case that
she's talking about when the opportunity
came we had actually we had to pull
people from other places to be able to
work with the government and for the
first two years it was a textbook case
of how you can really you know so j-pal
was going to evaluate it and be had
elections and then you know everything
got delayed and also to carry out j-pal
type research study you can't just up
and do it you have to have a certain
process which we miss the boat
essentially and so you know you have to
have enough
kind of
resources to be able to not for me for
example I feel like you know I don't
know how many more years I have left in
Pritam but it's really the scaling or
the spreading which is the exciting
thing our strategy right now is a big
community involvement because that will
be slower but it'll be deeper to get
local people to participate and then the
working with the government and again
you know if you work with ten
governments just by the law of averages
some will be doing fine and some will
not and so you can you know keep
yourself energized like you pee right
now is the one everybody's attention is
on you pee and like as soon as the
phases of the elections hit let's see
what it does
so I wish they could just delay the you
pee elections till after April 30th
because the schools will shut them you
know I want to pass a law which says
please do elections in the summer
holidays because it really screws up the
schools you know you know democracy is a
real you know problem for 4th but at
least the elections are I and I so I
think that's the real game and the
traditionally it's only the Foundation's
who have who are able to take the risk
that we will find people they will work
with the government and maybe nothing
will come of it and they have you know
been in the game long enough to know
that this is a long run game but
corporates and individuals have shot a
run vision so that's the I think
[Applause]
[Music]
you